myanmar's de facto leader aung san
tsuchi has told the un's top
court that there was no proof of
genocidal intent
behind her country's military campaign
against rohingya muslims
speaking before the international court
of justice in the hague the nobel peace
laureate said it couldn't be ruled out
that disproportionate force was used by
myanmar's armed forces
but she denied that any crimes committed
fell under the international definition
of genocide
more than 700 000 rohingya fled myanmar
to neighboring bangladesh to escape what
has been described
as an ethnic cleansing campaign
involving mass rapes
and killings let's hear what tsuchi had
to say
please bear in mind this complex
situation
and the challenge to sovereignty and
security in our country
when you are assessing the intent of
those who attempted
to deal with the rebellion surely under
the circumstances
genocidal intent cannot be the only
hypothesis
let's bring in dw correspondent max
sander he's following the proceedings
for us
in the hague and joins us for more hi
max good to see you
we saw aung san tsuchi speaking earlier
there at the international court of
justice
how would you sum up her defense
well asan said she had the same message
that she had time and time over again
she denies the accusations and she says
there was no genocidal intent at no
point in the last few years she
referenced the 2017
uprising against rohingya militants and
said that the state her government
carried out a simple
anti-terror operation against them and
she also said that at some point this
could have been excessive
but this is myanmar's responsibility to
deal with
not the responsibility of an
international court and she also said
quote unquote that no stone would be
left unturned
in order to bring those to justice who
have committed possible war crimes
and she also said that the mass exodus
of roughly 700
000 rohingya muslims to bangladesh is
tragic and that myanmar could have done
more in the past
to help diversity in this country max
you know we can't understate the fact
that aung san tsuchi she
is a nobel peace prize laureate she's
seen as an icon of peace
and yet she is here at the international
court of justice defending a regime
that's being accused of genocide
why would she take that risk
well first of all um the nobel the nobel
peace prize that she was awarded with uh
back in 1991 is it
is not in danger and the nobel peace
prize committee said last year had to
issue saw itself
forced to issue a statement that the
prize would be only awarded to people
would be awarded to people for their
acts in the past and that was against
the rules
to strip a nobel peace laureate off the
prize um
she is the foreign minister of myanmar
she's the de facto leader and she is
part of the regime herself and in her
eyes
this is an internal conflict and which
the west is now meddling in
and from what she said um there have be
there might have been problems with the
with with dealing with the insurgency in
the country but
her country is committed to the rule of
law and uh
wrongdoings will be brought to justice
and back home
um al sansoji has support of people
um right now from where i'm standing
right now i can actually see uh scores
of people standing out there with the
posters of
of their leader people who came from all
the way from from canada from
other countries in in europe uh here in
support uh uh
to to support their leader um so um this
may hurt your reputation on an
international level this case
but back home she does have the support
dw's correspondent
max sander reporting there for us from
the hague thank you very much
let's get more now on the alleged
atrocities that took place in rakhine
state and the way the hearing at the
hague is going down
in myanmar more than 700 thousand
rohingya muslims fled myanmar when the
military launched a crackdown in rakhine
state in august 2017 escaping what's
been described as an ethnic cleansing
campaign
most of the refugees now live in crowded
camps in bangladesh
they tortured our mothers and daughters
they burned our houses
they also raped me and i am grateful to
god that myanmar is facing trial for
that
although united nations investigators
called for genocide trials after finding
quote
the gravest crimes under international
law
no court has examined the evidence until
now
[Applause]
to defend her government at the hague
has both shocked her critics
and galvanized her supporters
we stand for her and we are on her side
and she stands for us she stands for the
whole burma she stands for
every religion every people of burma
every ethnicity of not only burmese i
came here to support i am a rohingya i
support to my peoples because
we are many suffering since long time
myanmar's government and its military
leaders continue to deny
accusations of ethnic cleansing and
genocide and maintain that what they
call their clearance operations were
essential to defend the country from
terrorists
genocide is a very difficult case to
prosecute legally
so but whatever happens win or lose it
will send a very strong message to
burma's generals
just three cases of genocide have been
recognized under international law since
world war ii
what happens in the hague this week will
have enormous repercussions for myanmar
it could face sanctions affecting
foreign investment and international aid
and we can speak now to david griffiths
he's the head of the secretary general's
office at amnesty international
in london david thank you for joining us
here on dw
i want to ask you about aung san
tsuchi's defense in front of the
international court of justice she said
earlier
there was no proof of genocidal intent
against the rohingya
what do you make of that
well i think aung san tsuchi has shown
us today
yet again how spectacular her fall from
grace
should has been she should be standing
shoulder to shoulder with the victims
and yet she's chosen to stand on the
side of the
military defending uh those accused of
horrendous atrocities against the
rohingya
and her defense today has has been
extremely thin she once again
fails to acknowledge the rohingya by
name she's failed to acknowledge
the severity and the scale of the
atrocities against them
and this level of denialism is both
dangerous and delusional
what do you think about these
proceedings david what are the
consequences for myanmar
well let's be clear the net is beginning
to tighten
and this is not the only mechanism that
is uh
that that could provide uh justice and
should provide justice for the rohingya
people who've been
so appallingly brutalized uh this has to
be the beginning and not the end
um and really you know the the this case
itself
could bring about some important
measures to protect
the 600 000 rohingya who are still at
risk
of uh atrocities from the myanmar
military
in rakhine state today living in an
apartheid regime that that's the first
and immediate consequence uh potentially
of this case
um but but it could and should also move
uh states and the u.n security council
into further action you know this needs
to be taken up by the
international criminal court referred by
the ice and
by the u.n security council states need
to
impose universal arms embargo targeted
sanctions against those
in the military who are responsible for
these atrocities
that that net is undoubtedly beginning
to tighten and this case is a really
important part of that
you mentioned what's at stake for the
rohingya here david they have said that
they are
seeking justice but what kind of actual
justice
could they get from this case
well as i said this is a this is one
stage and there need to be multiple
different avenues
no stone should be left unturned by the
international community in
seeking justice and that's both for the
uh the rohingya
um who have been directly targeted
uh and those who are at risk of further
uh atrocities in rakhine state so
you know this needs to be um a
pinprick to the conscience of the world
to pursue every possible avenue to bring
those responsible
to justice david griffiths head of the
secretary general's office at amnesty
international
in london joining us there thank you
very much
thank you